good morning everybody um that's not I
was thinking about my talk I was trying
to come up with a way to sort of tie
this into current events I got a laugh
out of that already I was thinking about
trying to come up with a joke but I
realized there wasn't really any good
joke that I could come up with it
it wasn't depressing to the American the
American audience
so instead let me say this in a it's
related to my talk so current events
sort of makes me realize how difficult
it is for groups of people who have you
know obsessively the same goal but very
different perspectives on things to try
to work together and to communicate okay
and our election is a microcosm our
macrocosm abet okay it just makes me
appreciate the opportunity to come to
Simon so that and thanks to the sort of
organizer of Simon's for me to be here
for the whole term but it lets me
appreciate that Simon's is a place where
people with a lot of different your
views on things can come together and
explain them to each other and you know
make the world a bit better of a place
so I kind of wonder whether Simon's
should maybe start a political version
of itself and try to to bring together
some people of different political views
and sort of communicate with each other
just the notion of truth and truth
but in the case the two perspectives I'm
going to talk about today are the sort
of the perspectives of certain
complexity and circuits and perspective
of descriptive like so much like I bet
Ben was talking about earlier so I'll
confess that I am when I see computation
I'm like Neil I think about circuits
rather than logics okay but I share the
same goal of trying to understand what
computation is and hopefully sort of our
ability to sort of shift between these
two models and maybe other ones can lead
us to a a a better understanding of what
what is computation so what I'm going to
talk about today is some joint work that
I did with Anuj when I did a postdoc in
Cambridge several years ago and what we
came up with was sort of a sort of
characterization of fixed point logics
in terms of a circuit model that's very
natural and sort of respects the
symmetry of the the fixed point logic
computation so some of my slides are
probably gonna be repetitive for things
that you saw last time so things that
Neil talked about and things that Ben
talked about I may repeat myself but I
know later when Greg talks are you gonna
repeat some of the things that I say so
I figure that's alright sure sure
doesn't help to repeat so the main
question that I'm interested in is is
there a logic that expresses exactly the
polynomial time computable properties
ablation 'el structures which are
unordered okay this is the question that
I'm interested and this is what Neil
spent a lot of time talking about
yesterday okay
as he also mentioned we know that when
we have an ordered structure fixed point
logic is able to do basically everything
that polynomial time can and I usually
call this the emmerman Barty result
and we also know that without this order
fixed-point logic is not very strong it
can't even determine what the size of a
universal structure is even or op all
right
so let me talk about a generalization on
this which you know also talked about
it's called FPC fix point logic with
Counting
it's basically iterated fixed one or
inflationary fixed point where you add a
counting mechanism and we know that this
is not P but it's it's also capable of
doing it lots of things so it's
interesting to study what's actually
able to do and formulas FPC there are
two types of variables one which range
over sort of the which a which is sort
of the the the base domain of the
structure and another sort of variables
which range over the numbers from zero
to the size of the structure alright and
these are connected via sort of this
counting quantifier hash hash tag
whenever I add u hash in class students
say you mean hash tag right so so hash
hash tag X of Phi 2 now denotes how many
times a particular element of the
universe satisfies Phi ok and we have
some numbers are naturally ordered in
the natural order is 0 1 2 3 up to up to
8 and we can use this this ordering
operator inside of our FPC formulas FPC
on its face it doesn't seem that
powerful but it's actually quite quite
strong there's some obvious polynomial
time algorithm so obvious means that the
the polynomial time algorithm you write
down is obviously sort of in FPC which
is sort of an iterative procedure on
some kind of structure one example of
this is the circuit value problem okay
so you're given a boolean circuit which
is a directed acyclic graph where the
internal gates are labeled with or and
or not and you're given some assignments
so the input gates and you want to
compute the
you that this circuit outputs if you you
perform these these operations between
each of the inputs it produces something
at the output okay this is a P complete
problem under sort of normal reductions
where you have an order but when you
don't have an order it's not necessarily
P complete anymore so the fact that you
can do this in in fix point logic
doesn't mean that you can do all of P in
fix my logic that requires an order if
you consider circuits which have in
addition just and or not gates but like
majority gates that say whether a
majority the inputs are true then they
requires additional quantifiers so
counting quantifiers that I talked about
last time if you already counting are
basically the same so I'll sort of use
them interchangeably feel free to ask
any questions that you have we're happy
to answer any questions okay there's
also some non trivial things and one of
them is this this result that was
mentioned yesterday this Hortons old by
Martin Gras which says that FPC captures
P you can compute all polynomial time
properties on proper minor closed
classes of grounds okay there's also
this interesting result that me and Anuj
and another postdoc Bjerke home head
which says basically if you encode it
the right way you can actually do linear
programming in fixed point with Counting
and you think about it the right way it
actually sort of follows via some sort
of encoding of the ellipsoid method in
fixed point logic anyway
we also know some problems can't be for
example is this very famous example of
the cipher your immerman graph which is
basically trying to determine whether
there's a twist or not in this graph
with a large separator right this can't
be done in fixed point County there's a
later result that says that in fact you
can't determine whether a system of
linear equations over a finite field is
solvable in FEC or not
and it's and it uses this as part of its
argument okay so that's fixed point with
fixed point with counting so that's one
side of the picture this is sort of the
descriptor of complexity side and now
I'm going to talk about the circuit
complexity side I'll probably go a
little bit fast on this because Ben just
told you about it so I'll move through
it quickly so we have some language of
strings of zeros and ones and we think
about them describing a function on each
input length so FN describes a function
on input like then two zero one okay we
can give a model for computing side
functions I say a circuit model so let
me just skip ahead to the picture okay
here's an example of a circuit it's a
directive basically graph I always put
the input through the bottoms and the
output at the top I know it's not always
standard but that's what I like to do
and for any given assignment of the
inputs say x1 equals 0 and x2 equals 1
we can compute an assignment for each
gate all right it's sort of in an int or
a procedure where you just sort of go
from the bottom to the top and compute
the value of the circuit we say that
such a language is in P slash poly if
the circuits for each FN the circuit CN
has some size P of n in the input okay
some polynomial alright so this is
typically called non-uniform circuits
because there's not a restriction on how
these circuits might be constructed
merely that they must have small size
all right we talked about sort of the
uniform version of this if there is an a
polynomial time way of taking the number
n to a some description some encoding of
the circuits yeah okay this is the kind
of uniform we'll talk about all the
stuff later could be done with stronger
notions of uniformity but
this suffice is to understand what's
going on okay these classes we could
also consider using majority gates in
addition to these and for this sort of
the standard model here it doesn't make
a difference because you can sort of
compute majority using other gates in
sort of polynomial size but it won't be
true in the sequel it'll be definitely
not true in the sequel so let me talk a
little bit about lower bounds here are
some lower bounds here's one of the more
famous ones by first second sip sir they
showed that a c0 cannot decide parity
there's some other work past that talked
about all of these this is the result
that been mentioned earlier leak and a
c0 and there's heard of his more recent
result by Ryan Williams it shows that
like AC c0 is not able to do endtime
exponential just not very strong but it
got a lot of press because it was sort
of the first progress in that
you said majority
in the case of constant if we know much
already doesn't make a difference yeah
yeah what about a monotone circuits if
you add majority piece you get something
more possible result and you can just
simulate you you there are monotone
circuits for majority about a depth I
guess you do and bounded depth monotone
okay
so that was sort of the background on
circuit complexity I think I'm going to
sort of try to push these two ideas
together all right so now we need to
talk about circuits to take inputs which
are graphs or structures right so so we
say a property of graphs so this is sort
of an isomorphism closed property of
graphs is recognized by a uniform
polymer size family of boolean circuits
security which is one for each input
length where each of the circuits CN has
the N squared edges or N squared inputs
for each of the potential edges in an in
vertex graph and each one is either 0 1
ok we have a size bound here and we have
that it's P uniform so uniform the only
sort of new thing is talking about
circuits which act on graphs ok and
there's no particular reason that we've
restricted ourselves to graphs you could
easily go to some more general
relational structure with some arbitrary
vocabulary it's easier for me to think
about graphs so each of the CNS actually
computes some function from N squared
bits to one bit and so here's where the
interesting property this is the
property of sort of isomorphism
invariants that it represents a graph
property computes a graph property we
say that a given circuit is invariant if
for
we graph okay the output of the circuit
is the same independent of how you stick
the graph into the circuit okay so every
way of permuting the vertices of this
graph and plugging it into the circuit
the output of the circuit is the same
okay so this is a sort of semantic
notion which says that these functions
follow this property it's not a
syntactic one right we can't necessarily
look at a circuit and say well you know
this this this is invariant fact it's
undecidable right but this sort of
motivates the next idea
so we describe a syntactic way of
encoding invariance so every circuit
that's encoded this way will naturally
be invariant all right so we say circuit
is symmetric if for every way of meeting
its inputs it induces a permutation of
this autom morphism of the circuit
itself okay so sort of the the sort of
this the automorphism structure of the
circuit witnesses the invariants the
invariance of the function it computes
all right so imagine here's a circuit
and for four reasons I decided not to
actually put actual gate levels when it
said I've just colored them okay because
this argument actually has nothing to do
with the gates there computed out the
serpent it's really a property of the
structure of the graphs all right so you
can think of these as and if you want
and that is an or all that really
matters is its its coloring things the
of the same gate the same color okay in
fact you can also think of this as
defined over sets like a nested family
of sets but I won't talk about that any
further any case so here's our inputs
and then we can think of this as a a
unary relation so it says whether a is
in the relation bees and relation C's in
the relation okay it does something here
there's some connection then here's the
output alright so we can look at some
permutation of the inputs so here's a
permutation which flips B and C all
right and we can look at what happens to
the circuit as we do this alright so we
flip B and C that means a stays this
because a is fixed by this right
basically what it does is it induces a
swap between these two it induces the
autumn or for some induced by this
permutation is fixed here and fixed here
and you can see why this one's
definitely fixed because it has all a B
and C as inputs so it's naturally fixed
by anything all right and you sort of
look at this level by level you can see
the top gate it's also fixed and if you
you think about it a little bit more you
can see that actually under all
permutations the top gate is fixed and
that's why it's computing an invariant
function questions
so the gate has to be fixed under the
yes so we can look at versions which are
not competing a boolean function but
instead like a relation and then the
output gates do you move around because
you have more than one but for this
version just think about it having a
single application because it's
computing an invariant thing so it
should be straightforward that it's easy
to it's easy to argue that any invariant
or any symmetric circuit computes an
invariant function but the converse is
not true okay there are some invariant
functions which have no symmetric
circuits and we'll show that later on so
here's an example of an invariance
here's an example of a bearing graph
properties so for example whether the
number of edges in a graph is even or
odd
yeah that's an invariant thing and one
way to do that would be sort of to
divide the edges in half computed there
even or oddness and then join them
together and with one gate
you could repeatedly do this this is not
a symmetric circuit right even though
it's computing an invariant property
so there's sort of two directions to our
results we basically show that
fixed-point logic is capable of doing
anything that symmetric circuits can do
and symmetric circuits are capable of
doing anything that fixpoint logic you
do so one of the directions is
relatively easy so if we have a formula
of say fixed point logic or fixed point
logic with counting it's relatively
straightforward to turn it into a a
small symmetric circuit which is uniform
okay and let me just briefly sketch out
the idea so if you have a first order
formula you can convert it into a
constant depth poli-sci symmetric
boolean circuits basically what you do
is you look at every sub formula in
every way of assigning to the free
variables that will induce a gate okay
and you connect the gates according to
how they're sort of arranged in the sub
formula so if you have an existential
quantifier it looks like a giant or you
have a universal quantifier it looks
like a giant hand the other correct
connect is as appropriate you can sort
of lift this up to fix point logic by
translating the fixed point allotted for
being to a a much deeper first-order
formula by iterating it we sort of
Paulette polynomial depth but with the
property that the number of free
variables is bounded by some constant
sort of what appears in the the original
formula right so you can still perform
the same procedure and you get
polynomial size because the number of
free variables is bounded by some
constant and then the step to get to
fixed point with counting is that you
now have to add majority gates you
basically the same thing but in order to
handle you know these majority majority
quantifiers you use the majority gates
okay questions
I know what this is this part this is
the easy buddies this is just the
transformation from a formula with no
ordering to a symmetric circuit yes
transmission just--can standard yes okay
so a little bit of time here so I'm
gonna skip ahead a little bit so we can
ask several questions so we can first
ask whether the polynomial size family
of symmetric boolean circuits that
determine cardinality of the number of
edges okay answer so this is know as I
mentioned before but I'll point out why
that is it a bit
another question we might ask are does
majority somehow help you in some
inherent way does adding majority doing
majority instead of boolean if you do
that in symmetric circuit so there's
somehow more powerful okay and so this
one is yes okay
because majority can do this but boolean
cannot so yes it is more powerful so
this is just a corollary of this answer
you might ask whether every invariant
circuit can be captured by a equivalent
symmetric majority circuit the answer
this one is definitely no and that's
because there are varying properties
like the CFI graph that we know aren't
and FBC so if we argue that symmetric
majority circuit so following size are
FPC then they can't do them okay so
here's sort of our main results in
there's terms two parts one is for
boolean circuit someone is for majority
circuits so we say a class of graphs is
accepted by AP uniform family of
polynomial size symmetric boolean
circuits I know there's a lot of
quantifiers we're all clear on what they
mean I think only the only really new
one here is this one okay if and only if
it's definable a fixed point logic
formula which is interpreted in some the
base structure that you care to say
something about plus another sort of
number sort which is linearly ordered
and they're separate there's no
connection between these two things okay
other than this is the same size set
matter second result says that if you
look at Palmilla size symmetric majority
circuits they are the same as fixed
point with County ok and what County
allows you to do is sort of connect
these two things so it allows you to
count two final sets here and get
numbers out okay so what this gives is
that a very natural circuit based
characterization to a fixed point with
counting define ability which is not our
original goal but I'll say what our
original goal was at the end but it's a
very natural description of fixed point
logic with counting and that sort of
satisfied me because I looked at these
these weird things that I didn't really
understand I said okay well now here's a
circuit for those things right so it
helped me I don't know if it will help
you maybe another natural consequence is
that if we can prove some in Express
ability results for a fixed point with
County formula that also provides some
kind of lower bound for that circuit
class all right and sort of the goal is
to sort of cross-pollinate ideas from
these two things if we can have some
kind of characterization of you know
this this notion of computation in both
worlds maybe techniques from one side
can help on the other and vice versa
okay so let me talk a little bit about
prior work it was as far as I know it
was first discussed in this paper by
denaburg driven and sherlock in 1986
about first order two final things and
we have some connection to that but it's
a little bit tenuous our bein as for
asian was this nice work by martin otto
in the mid 90s
who gives a characterization of the fine
ability of infinitary logic in terms of
something called a coherent locally
polynomial symmetric circuits and the
ideas are actually very similar okay
even the techniques are somewhat similar
the two main differences
our Martin looks at sort of infinite
things infinite circuits okay
and we only look at finite things I only
care about finite circuits and the
second one is the notion of uniformity
our notion of uniformity is P uniform
and the notion of uniformity here it's
called coherent it means that sort of a
family of its circuits concur embed in
larger versions of those circuits all
the way up alright there's a way of
embedding into a larger circuit okay so
I have about ready to end earlier on
time I'll just keep talking until
someone chops me up okay and we sort of
build it on this notion of a supporting
partitioner or support that that Martin
uses okay here's our main theorem again
let me just sort of sketch the proof
already did half of it though that was
the easy half okay that's what I
sketched several pages back you know
sort of the harder part is showing that
given a symmetric circuit of this kind
we can come up with a way of deciding
what it would output in fixed point with
counting okay and here's sort of the
overall sketch it's three steps here but
it's it's more involved than this first
we show that the automorphism group of
each gate is somehow captured by the
behavior of how a small number of
vertices of the input graph move right
and we can label each gate by this this
small set of vertices and we call this
small set of vertices at support okay if
you want intuition what it meant in this
version of the proof was the sort of
free variables that you assigned okay
that's sort of what support looks like
from the other end okay
what this will allow us to do is it will
allow us to succinctly encode how a gate
evaluates under every permutation of the
input graph because we actually only
care about how the permutation of the
Impa graph moved the support alright and
this is much smaller than the total set
of size n it's just some constant K so
we really only have to matter about how
a constant number of the
by any given permutation and that will
tell us you know how the gate will
evaluate and then so basically what we
do is we use the P uniformity of this
circuit family to construct it on the
number sort to build up the supports for
each of these gates and then go through
the circuit and use this property to
compute whether it evaluates to true or
false based on how the support is
assigned and we're using them remove all
ready theorem there because you know
it's completely ordered because it's a
number sort so anything we want to do we
can just do there that makes life a lot
easier okay so that's the overall sketch
of the argument I think I'm just going
to the end and talk about other
interesting things I had some technical
stuff so I could talk about okay so
thanks for we counting we know is not
able to do all of invariant polynomial
function there we know that okay so
they've been some work studying what
could we do instead all right so this
work that Anuj and others initiated
looks at considering fixed point logics
but instead of you know counted
quantifiers you allow the ability to
compute the rank over a finite field
alright so that was sort of the
obstruction that I mentioned way back
and so you're saying well if you add
this up truck ability to solve this
obstruction what can you do and I think
that Gregg is going to talk about this
in his talk so I won't talk about any
further I'll give it to him another sort
of direction is this direction of
choiceless polynomial time by under s
yuri and yuri which says that which is
sort of a more abstract machine while
it's kind of like some weird version of
a Turing machine and in fact our
original motivation for this whole work
I mean it was sort of the basis of work
so I I was looking at that I was saying
well what is this actually correspond to
in computation I was like okay so what
circuit model is this and this is what
we figured out we figured out FPC but we
didn't figure out this yeah this was our
goal to come up with a circuit Malthus
we did not succeed so if anyone has any
thoughts about that I would be
definitely interested in talking about
that that's one last slide and then I'll
finish so another direction I want to
think about that is sort of more from my
I think of things a circuit model we
could naturally consider arithmetic
circuits a set of boolean circuits so
instead of and or nots you could talk
about plus minus and times and think
about having matrices as inputs rather
than graphs as inputs right there are
lots of interesting problems that have
this format right so here are some two
polynomials which are buried in the
original sense of invariance that we had
for when we talked about boolean
problems right so the determinant
polynomial looks like this I'll show you
further that you probably also have
heard of the permanent polynomial which
is it's much scarier Big Brother they
both look similar
they're both symmetric in the same or
they're both invariant in the same sense
but we think that this one is easy and
this one is hard okay we know this one
is easy and we think this one is hard
okay in fact sort of the best algorithm
that we have for doing the permanent is
algorithm well this formula due to
Reiser
there's some more modern version of this
but they're basically the same in terms
of how big they are this is a symmetric
circuit or symmetric formula right you
might ask question is this the best
symmetric circuit you could come up with
for this right
if you require symmetry is this the best
that you can do okay
so sort of have two questions the first
question is can we solve determinant
using small symmetric circuits it's not
clear that you can we know that you can
solve it using small circuits which
don't have this symmetry restriction
there goes through something called
algebraic branching programs at least
the more recent burdens do so you might
ask whether we can turn these sort of
these constructions that we already have
for determinants into symmetric ones I
don't know where the answer is yes or no
not that I'm aware of but what was the
question I thought I would have thought
the standard algorithm for determining
this is cement
I don't it's just this matrix
multiplication what are you talking
about you might have to define a linear
order on something which which are
really talking about I just take a
matrix well talk it offline yeah anyway
so that's a I think this is probably
easier to answer than this one but the
the alternate question is can we show
that permanent requires large symmetric
circuits okay and there has been some
work on this that I didn't really
realize it's kind of in a different
domain it's looking at this problem of
computing the the permanent as a
projection of the determinant and what
Landsberg and rusts array showed last
year was that you can't compute the
permanent with a symmetric projection of
the determinant yeah which is we sort of
in this direction
it's a weaker result and showing you
doesn't have small symmetric circuits
but it's in the same direction I think
I'll just end with this slide here and
just advertise that Greg is going to
talk about
okay so you asked whether anyone has
circuit view of trusses polynomial time
the answer is yes sure
in fact I think his original version of
choices polynomial time was in terms of
sub circuits with a very strange rule
for cutting off the computation one of
threatens to get to bait and URI and I
sort of looked at that is that after a
while hey wait a minute this is just
absolute state machine is up or down
through a fairly finite sense let's go
ended up that way I think so
I think shots original version is his
view of the situation persisted into his
write-up of the zero one of our four
choices polynomial so there are two
papers doing that one by sheriff himself
and one by European me you and I used
the what we consider the standard
absolute state machine approach to this
but if I remember correctly sheriff's
paper on this given the first paper
giving that proof was written in terms
that are at the very least closer to
circuits than anything that URI and I
have done okay I'll take a look at that
Thanks there's a question
so there's some beautiful virginal
circuits you choose some different
operations no I mean there's there's
lots of choices you can make in terms of
basis in the normal polynomial size
setting it doesn't really matter too
much I mean obviously the the gates have
to be somehow computable or I mean you
can't say put like an Oracle for solving
the halting problem into your your
circuit right without sort of breaking
the notion of reasonably computable I'm
not sure I'm understanding your question
it does yes right so so Rankin is one
such operation that makes a difference
so you can do things with rank that you
couldn't do without it I don't think
that I have too many more examples now
because it's weird and that it's sort of
the normal setting we have the order
none of this matters anything that you
compute apollon time you can just make a
gate of your circuit if you feel like it
but in this version it does matter as
you mention Craig what we talk about
this later
and one who's out there is then what
majority of course can do any fully
symmetric function so you so as long as
you restrict yourself to gates which are
fully symmetric the majority is enough
because you can compute any fully
symmetric function by using majority
with different numbers of padded
constants of it
thank you